i remember writing hold back the river
and everybody at the label jumping for
joy and thinking that they had a hit on
their hands
i dreamt about being on those stages in
front of all the people that my heroes
were in front of
i remember this burning desire i was
dead certain that i wanted it more than
everyone
chaos in the calm comes out debbie is
the number one that's crazy and the
winner is jasper thank you so much this
is insane nobody could have made us
understand it was going to be traumatic
who i was
on the chaos and the calm campaign i
needed to stop all of that for my soul
and my mental health yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] intense
ed sheeran invited me to open for him in
football stadiums around europe and the
bit i hate to admit and i'm anxious to
confess is that
life can take a toll on people to be
male and talk about your
feelings it was more about can you suck
it up though it's all like an act
would you do it all again
i'm really concerned about what happens
next
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this
yourself
[Music]
james
so you're a 90s baby yeah 1990 same as
me 1992. okay what about those early
years
defined you
and the person you would go on to be
when you look back at the dots and say
well that that and that
is the reason i am who i am what are
those first dots i grew up in a in a
kind of commuter belt town called
hitching in hertfordshire which is about
an hour outside of the centre of london
i hated going into london it's horrible
busy noisy smelly awful
the quiet calm of my little hometown was
perfect it was safe
pretty much safe
um
i'm the youngest of of me and my brother
um and then there's my parents my mum
and my dad and we don't have
my i only have one cousin who was born
10 years after i was born
so we were small family it wasn't a big
crowd it wasn't the sort of noisy
experience growing up uh in that respect
my parents are pretty fiery people
and
they're kind of
party animals in a way they they're very
social
they're very loud and and and um kind of
excitable
so i feel
that that was going on all the time they
had people around all the time and they
kind of i suppose inspired me and my
brother to sort of be okay in all sorts
of social situations
and uh
i think all kids myself included go
through moments of shyness and moments
where they're a little more outgoing
than maybe a little more shy again than
outgoing again
i remember most vividly the sort of
shire times and i stood behind
my older brother
who would lead
nine out of 10 times into any situation
with other kids or whatever
so i felt
i was a more timid
person
gentle
compared to my parents and my brother
who were more
um
just louder
well your parents affectionate
in a kind of
uh
i want to say like wartime ways stiff
upper lip kind of way my
dad was older than other dads
um still a great dad
but he might you know he was 42 when i
was born
uh he's nearly 75.
and
he comes from like very well his parents
were
you know his dad was flying
fighter planes in the second world war
most of uh
my friends
parents
parents parents like there's there's
another generation usually involved
whereas for me it was my dad's dad who
was doing that
so
my parents come from this
you've asked if they were affectionate
uh they were affectionate in their sort
of steely way
[Music]
it wasn't
it wasn't
sweet and sugary
and cuddly
to be honest
for example
when i showed some vague interest in
performing of any kind
my mum
was less oh that's nice she wasn't
really that wasn't her
energy her energy was like okay if
you're into it do it and do it like mean
it
go on
like it was it was with a bit of a smile
it wasn't like it was like it was
encouraging and i got on board with it
but um
ultimately it was like
if you're gonna give it a shot don't
don't do it by half
look at and she'd name any one of my
heroes
and or any one of her heroes musically
you know my parents are big music fans
she said look at what they give it
you've got to give it that
and without quite saying it she was
saying
you know you have to be believable it's
all like an act
um so
affectionate
they were encouraging and and they were
excited by for example when i got into
music and wanting to play an instrument
and performing and all that they were
excited about it i think but they
weren't like if i wasn't into it they
weren't
you know if if
the one and a half times in the early
early days that i kind of went oh i
don't know if i want to play guitar
actually it's probably a bit hard they
weren't like oh
and they weren't saying try harder then
they were just like
okay
what about your dad then when he finds
out that you want to be you know you
might want to pursue that avenue well
one thing my dad and both my parents um
said a lot about
and kind of required of me
was that i would do something to earn
some money and actually go back to i was
12 or 13
when they first said pocket money's done
and i think i know a lot of kids who are
getting that until sort of 16 at the
time
some of them longer
because there was various kids whose
parents weren't
they didn't need their kids to get a job
they just wanted their kids to be kids
and
have a nice time and i guess it's not
that my parents didn't want me to have a
nice time but from like 12 years old
they were like there are jobs you can
get there's a paper round there's this
there's that and there was a my dad
who had loved music and going to see
music live since he was you know much
younger since way before me and my
brother came along
he was definitely like there's a job at
the market like so-and-so's kid is
working down at the market
go and ask him how he got the job try
and get the other shift and i did i got
that shift my brother got one of the
shifts as well and at 13
in january
at 4 00 am i was on my bike on the way
to the market in the dark
shivering my nuts off
i remember the like anxiety dreams that
i would have before getting up for that
because as a teenager i just wanted to
be asleep
for hours and hours and hours and you're
supposed to like we know more about that
now it's like really good for teenagers
to get as much sleep as they can kids of
any age but teenagers apparently very
important my dad didn't know any of that
not interested
you know if james wants to buy guitar
strings because he's snapping him off
his guitar all the time and i can't he's
like i can't keep paying for that
which i respect
i didn't know the time
um
my dad and my mum
but also because my dad had had jobs as
a as a kid you know helping someone a
like a
you know a corner shop or something he
he like heartily believed in that and
was trying to instill that in us
from clearly you know very early on
because whatever our hobby might have
been
he's like i don't want to have to fund
it
and i understand that we don't come from
money
you know we don't my mum was sometimes
working and sometimes not because you
know she was being a stay-at-home mom
half a time
um
but um my dad was was you know bringing
in the the big bit that that paid for
the family to sort of exist
um
yeah so he he was uh
he believed
as long as we could sort of fund the
things that we wanted to do more or less
then
they were doable
you talk a lot about how um having idle
time is really really important to
discovering who you are and being a
creative and
and finding yourself
something it's actually a concept that
i've not really heard before talked
about from from my guests is the
importance of just having
a window of time and i imagine even
today when it comes to creativity that's
that's maybe a big part of your creative
process can you talk to me about that
that early age then how idle time helped
you to become who you are
um
almost against the odds basically it
helped me become who i am today
and it helped feed my creative
everything um what do i mean by that
my mum's the type of person who so when
i was a kid in the house you know if i
if i was
having some idle time
another way to say that if i wasn't
doing anything
middle of the afternoon
she'd be on me like you know straight
away or my brother like what are you
doing
you can't do nothing
you could tidy your room you could come
and clean this thing for me you could go
out the back garden and do this thing
for me you could do that
what do you mean you're doing nothing
that's my that's a vivid memory
and it's not like unfair
i i respect it in certain ways but i
know as a at this point someone who's
sort of
professionally kind of creative and you
know wound up in a position where i can
sort of call that my job that it's very
important
to be staring out the window there was
some quote i can't remember who said it
and somebody told me the other day and i
haven't got any sort of reference names
for you sorry but a guy said uh let's
just say it was einstein einstein
perfect
um einstein's wife said to him what are
you doing he was looking out the window
he said i'm working
and that was it
and it's perfect for a creative that
because it's bang on
if i'm staring out the window into space
as the rest of us might say
then it just looks like i'm staring in
space
but i'm probably having an idea for a
song or a lyric or working something
over in my head i find it hard to say
that stuff to you or anybody without
worrying that i sound pretentious or
like a bit of a dick
um
but i know that's the experience when i
was a kid
thinking about something i wanted to
draw whatever it may have been and
having some of this like idol time
like i said my mum is like on me like
no that's not okay
so maybe that's why i
i'm sort of concerned even now
that i look
like a
pretentious
idiot no i i can i have to say i
completely agree and it's it's
logically it makes a ton of sense that
you have to clear the mind to allow new
ideas to arrive and that we all i mean
every business every person that works
in the business will know the best ideas
don't come from a boardroom they don't
come when you're trying to think of them
they come when you go for a walk or
you're in the shower yeah all these
places where you have that space yeah um
so it makes perfect sense i remember
david gilmour and pink floyd said every
time i sit down guitar in hand to write
a song in that really creative mood i
want to write a song and i'm going to
and it's going to be great nothing comes
and it's it is generally that way
so it's quickly a long time ago it
quickly made me understand and sort of
cherish the opportunity to
sit around
with the tools nearby
and just exist and think and dream
and
play
by which i mean play guitar play music
but just play
creatives and just people generally i
think
have a lot of guilt
associated with
just sitting around but it seems to be
so incredibly imperative to creation
it's a huge huge part of it it's
probably 95 of the reason why it ever
works if it ever works
95 of it is about
having you not not watching a clock
not there not being any sort of
consequence and we put i put hundreds of
consequences on myself
we all do
um
but as soon as you do those things
the kind of the quality
starts to sort of
lessen
um
so yeah it didn't help that experience
when i was a kid
of my mum sort of going no no no no no
get yourself busy yeah you got you know
if you're not you know it was almost if
you're not if i don't see you kind of
playing and and and getting something
from the playing then you're not
spending your time you could be helping
me you could be doing this you could be
doing that is there is there a is there
some homework you haven't done and yeah
there probably was like hundreds of bits
of homework i hadn't done but i was
already so into
trying to write a song or get better at
playing the guitar or being creative in
some other way
that of course i was pushing the
homework under the rug
um
but that
unfortunately that that even that small
sort of pressure that i felt then has
ended up as like so many like you say
you've met so many creative people who
feel that sort of guilt
it has um
heightened the sense of guilt so it's a
strange one to juggle
and uh
and i find myself fighting against it
and that's a that's really inconvenient
to what i'm trying to do
as a passion and actually for a living
suddenly
what insecurities did you have at that
young age i spend a lot of time talking
about all of mine but no man someone
about your theirs um
insecurities i had an insecurity so in
school in like primary school as a young
kid
i was um i was a fast runner
i was good at drawing and painting i had
this a selection of things that i was
good at and like the talk in the
classroom was that i was the best at
running
i was one of the best at football i was
the best at drawing
and i'm not fully sure how
but that started quickly to really
matter to me
to the point that as far as you know
what insecurities did i have
i
i think back
about the worries that i had about what
if one day i'm not the fastest
and what if somebody draws something
better than me
and i hate to admit that i don't know
why i felt those things
but
i had i had an ambition and a dr and a
drive
that
wanted to
be really really good
at
these things um
and as a kid yeah i wanted to sort of be
able to feel like i was the best at them
why do you know why i don't know well i
know it's dangerous territory is what i
wanted to say i know now as an adult
that's dangerous territory
because there's enjoying things and
being really good at them
and then there's a there's a difference
between that and whatever somebody
decides is the best why
one
theory as to why
one of my theories i suppose just as i
think about it now
is that i could maybe then sort of
maybe i could validate
idle time
i think i really enjoyed
and to this day i really enjoy
are having an endless amount of time and
space to create
and i'll throw that thing about being
the fastest runner sort of off the table
for a minute because it doesn't really
sort of relate to the context of
the other things i loved then that have
sort of fed through into my life now
um
why why why was i why did i worry about
that stuff
but yeah i wanted to i wanted if if i
could be if i could say people think i'm
really good at this then i could have
a reason
for why i
should be allowed any amount of time
to focus on them
and you could present that evidence to
who
my parents
anybody
trying to stop me doing it
a part of my conscience because i have a
conscience that feels guilty if i i'm
looking at the clock all the time it
made me a very punctual person
but i also look at the clock out of
paranoia how much time have we got how
much time have i got and it shouldn't
matter at all to creativity that
but i find myself doing it all the time
you know i actually i i have a baby now
we have a nine-month-old daughter and
and and um adam ada adam
some people do pronounce it some of you
it is much better to be fair i learned
this but um
lucy went out to kader out the other day
and because lucy's the absolute greatest
she was like it'll just give you a load
of time to just
have a guitar
you know next to you and think about
the things that you sort of you see what
i'm getting at she just gave me
hey you just do you for a bit
and gift it's a it's a that was a uh
incredibly generous given now i know
what it's like to be you know a
first-time parent and it's it's a it
takes a village um
uh
and still an hour into that time i knew
i was an hour into that time because i
looked at the clock
i didn't need to
but i still carry it
uh
it's [ __ ] frustrating
was there any anyone in your circle at
that early age that made you feel like
that wasting
weight quote wasting time or not using
time in a evidently productive way was
meant that you were a lazy person yeah
is that it was
that was part of the language of of of
who and what i grew up around
um
you know
yeah like i say like we didn't we
weren't a sort of
we weren't like a particularly wealthy
family neither were any of the sort of
friends that that
that my family had or that you know
everyone was somewhere between
working class and sort of just about
middle class
but i felt a lot of penny pinching all
the time partly probably because of what
my parents come from so how they operate
so and it felt like middle class
came like later in life
i think my parents are there now but
like that's slightly sort of besides the
point what i mean is
um
time was precious
uh
and you had to the the the language
around
idle time was you know don't waste it
before anybody had thought about what
anybody was doing with idle time they
were already being told not to waste it
that was a that was
yeah in my wider circle as a kid
around you know my my family and my
family friends and friends of friends
that was the energy
so there was like a pressure
and there was of course yeah a narrative
that that said
oh he just sits around all the time he's
so lazy not directly to me necessarily
but if anybody was doing any sitting
around of any kind for any prolonged
amount of time
lazy
guy so it was a negative thing
and i felt a pressure and a sort of
self-conscious
need to stay away from that
while all the while i absolutely kind of
craved it for for being a creative kid
who wanted to draw and paint and explore
music did you get the impression that
people in your family and close to you
had high hopes for your future
you know i do think
that they thought i really wanted
the kind of things i've achieved
i do think that they believed i wanted
this stuff
and i think they saw that
in my
how how i went about my days
um
i remember a friend of mine who's still
such a good friend of mine matt
we learned to play guitar together me
and tom who i mentioned who who plays
bass in my band
and and matt and my brother alex and i
you know we were all playing guitars at
the same time learning to do this that
the other
and me and matt were doing our gcses and
we were in like a biology class
we did the same we had the same science
class
and we were talking and matt is a
brilliant beautiful soul
who
is sort of
he's a total party animal but he's
wonderfully sort of earnest in his own
way as well
and we were we were sharing the
pressures of what we're supposed to do
after our gcses after our a-levels are
we going to do uni oh my god who are we
going to be what are we going to do
and he said man
one thing's for sure i don't think
you'll ever have an office job
and i knew how he meant it and i really
i really appreciated it and i've never
forgotten it and i think i've i've
brought it back to him i've brought it
up with him again
since
and in a strange way it felt like he was
a guy you know you asked what my parents
would say well he
was someone who was very close to me at
the time as well
who i felt believed in me
what's funny is he was one of 10 of us
who were all starting to play the guitar
at the same time we all
looked at
jimi hendrix or the red chili peppers or
any of our our rock heroes
in the same way and we wanted it we
wanted that because you do when you're
14. yeah i want to do that
and i remember this burning desire
and i can't tell you even to this day
whether it was the same or less or more
than any of the other guys
but in the moment i was dead certain
that i wanted it more than everyone
and i did sit with my parents some
nights with some music on the tv or on
the radio or or coming off the record
player
and almost get emotional about how badly
i wanted to do that kind of thing make
that kind of
sound like when i grow up was the sort
of thing i was saying
and they didn't take the piss out of me
they were very straight faced about it
i think they like i think it excited
them and obviously they had no idea if
it was actually going to happen
but
they did encourage it so
my very long-winded answer to your
question if you called them up is
yeah i think they i think they
would have believed or hoped that i'd
sort of got close maybe even half as
close as i've come
um
yeah and off you go to study music right
in brighton
um
it's it was it's really a wonderful
thing to hear that one of the real sort
of catalyst moments in your early career
was
just a clip of someone some punter in a
pub recording you
singing yeah that ended up on youtube
youtube and i will say it was at a time
when
there were youtube sensations popping
into the charts getting signed by big
record labels very exciting because they
got 500 000 views overnight they put the
video up at 7 pm and by 7 am add million
views had 2 million views
that video that went online with me it
was there for six weeks or more
25 views maybe
maybe 26 views
um
and i didn't i wasn't i hadn't thought
about it i met the guy because he filmed
me and he said i'll put it online
you know he'll do like a little sort of
filter on it little edit
thanks man
great i'm just glad you you liked my
song
and i didn't hear about it until this
record label found it with its 25 views
and they called up my manager i had a
manager at the time still same manager i
got today
called him up and said we'd love we love
this we'd love to meet you meet james
um
can we fly you to new york which was a
sort of that's where they were based
that the record label it was just a very
whirlwind exciting experience just to go
and meet these guys they just wanted me
to come and sit and sort of play for
them like in the flesh
and um and so i did and they went on to
be the label that i signed to after a
second visit and it was all very
exciting given that it feels like you
know that was one of a million open mic
nights that i was performing at at that
time just rolling up putting my name
down playing three songs moving on to
the next one what has that taught you
about
knocking on doors and you never know
which one's gonna open you know what i
mean because
as you say people look at that and go
are [ __ ] so lucky you know but um
what does that what has that told you
about
the nature of how life happens and
i guess it's taught me to use the idle
time
my idle time in that in those years was
long empty evenings
that i filled with finding open mic
nights
to hone my craft sounds a bit
pretentious again but it's exactly what
i was doing it's exactly what i was
doing and it's exactly what i'm doing at
every gig i do today the only difference
is that there seems to be some people
today who are actually there to see me
and they've done a bit of homework they
say they like my songs and that's so
flattering but every single show i do to
this day i just want to be a bit better
i just want to deliver a slightly more
effortless every time more effortless
hopefully more moving
and enjoyable experience for the people
standing in front of me back then
it was seven or eight maybe 11 or 12
people smattered around a bar privately
trying to have a drink probably after
work trying to catch up and i'm in the
corner
barking
and they have they don't know who i am
and they haven't they haven't paid to
see me or anything and
i want their attention
and i don't just want their attention i
want the thing that i've written to be
good enough to effortlessly turn their
head
that's how it has to go
and i had a lot of time to fill with
those
um trials it was all trials uh it's all
training
um so i did and i remember earlier than
when that thing was when that guy filmed
me in that bar i remember years before
that when for example i was taking a
couple of originals and a couple of
covers to an open mic night and people
really enjoyed my delivery of the covers
which was really encouraging
um
and then i'd do an original they i i'd
play the verse and they just talk
talking away and i play the chorus and
they're still talking then i'd play the
bridge
and a few heads would turn and i think i
go home that night thinking the bridge
has got something but the other bits
need work clearly the other bits need
work because i didn't have them in the
verse and i didn't have them in the
chorus
but i had them in the bridge
and that's why it was all training and
so i go home this is when i'd moved to
brighton actually particularly
i had a lot of idle time between lessons
and
the course i was doing
and i filled it with just trying to be
better just soaking up i was going to
record shop this is just right before
streaming sort of exploded
uh it wasn't like a thing so i was
buying records still
um
the difference i suppose for my
generation at times i put them on my
computer and stick on my mp3 and i could
walk around without a stack of cds in my
pocket
or in my bag anyway
i was soaking up as much as i possibly
could
[Music]
just trying to get better trying to
create
a more
enjoyable experience for anybody who's
in front of me because that's all i love
about music
and that's what i want that's why i want
to do it because
for some reason i want to be able to
create that for other people
people often overlook that part but it
seems to be if there was a sort of a
through line or a common
thread between all the guests i sit here
with whether they're comedians or their
music artists the ones that have become
really successful and also really unique
and
and yeah unique is the right word really
unique
is you get this like bit before where
they were
performing to no one and kind of just
doing it for the love of it for
themselves and it seems to be that that
in fact that moment is the defining
moment when no one's there when there
isn't the arenas and there's that part
there that 10 000 hours part that they
talk about
is the most important part
somehow i think it probably is
everything that might follow that or
that does or everything that followed
that for me has been so important
but there are moments in the very
beginning for anybody whatever they're
doing that are vital to how to what
happens next
um
10 000 hours is is the right like
description and reference
um
and all those open mic nights
and i was busking when i was in brighton
as well which is kind of wild you're
just walking down the street with a
guitar on your shoulder and then you
stop
amongst all the other people you're
walking next to and you have the balls
the confidence somehow the courage
to start singing at people in the middle
of the street
it was always terrifying until i was
sort of
getting into the first chorus of a song
and then i could almost sort of blend in
um
but but give it some to try and catch
some people anyway
those all of that those times
they are vital
it's about
learning about what doesn't work it's
about sometimes you know
there's people who are like
hell-bent on
talking over you and they've every right
to
they've every right to
um if they haven't come to see you
intentionally or or it's not a private
you know actual sort of venue where
people buy tickets to come up then
they've every right to and and it's how
it was always about how i managed in
those situations
i remember
going into noisy pubs that wanted to
hold an open mic night at the same time
and someone plugging me into a pa saying
go on i mean thinking this place is
rammed and they're all just having the
greatest night of their lives just
having a big old chat and they're
drinking their pints and all this and
i've gotta sing into this and i remember
being so excited
i remember thinking
i'm gonna get them all
i don't know that it worked every single
time but i i remember winning over rooms
and leaving so these weren't open mic
nights actually i remember in between
the open mic nights there'd be some
individual who'd seen me and say will
you come and play at my pub which felt
like a real win
will you come and play at my pub on
thursday night on saturday night
whatever it might be sunday night
i say yeah all right and half the time
they'd say there's 20 quid in it for you
and i say all right absolutely
play for an hour sure
you could pay me nothing to play for two
hours at that time and i'd have done it
i just wanted the opportunity the stage
the microphone the opportunity
and i remember yeah a couple of like
really busy rooms for the people who had
no idea who i was and i remember you
catch some eyes and people going oh
there he is you know another guy
plugging in a guitar
you know
let's all sort of speak up a bit when he
sort of pipes up
i remember thinking i'm gonna get you
it's interesting one of the really
interesting things i was just thinking
about as you're explaining that story is
how
the environment in which you started
your career in those pubs noisy pubs
trying to you know get people's
attention
you described it as actually changing
the music you would go home and say okay
the chorus held them yeah but this part
didn't so the environment actually
changed the creative because you you
realize that attention
you learnt very early that their tension
is is the thing we'll all listen to a
good song
yeah
but you know people forget the ones that
aren't good enough
that's a that's a a quite a sort of
brutal sort of comment in itself because
i i you know i can't guarantee that
every song i've ever written will hold
every room in the world every time
but i still love it enough to try it
again and try harder um so yeah it does
it does change to me it absolutely
changes the music because
until i changed those things
i was just playing i was playing
something that wasn't because i was
often going back to the same rooms
not always and it always eventually
changed but i would go back to the same
place because that's just another place
that i knew i could go and play a few
songs
um
and if across a two-week period i didn't
get around to changing some stuff and i
still played the same song then it just
wasn't every time it wasn't working
every time i was getting them for the
same minute in the song maybe it was the
second chorus or something so yeah it
you have to adapt if you just keep
taking the same thing and ultimately
flogging a dead horse
i was never if i kept doing that i was
never going to
be on any any of the stages that i'd
seen my heroes on you know when i was a
kid at home and i was being affected by
all that stuff i saw on tv on vh1 pop-up
video or even music in movies or or any
live stuff that i got to see on tv you
know that was broadcast on tv um i
dreamt about being on those stages in
front of all the people that my heroes
were in front of
so many people singing their words back
and i was never going to get there if i
just stubbornly took around the same
song that i wrote when i was 17 that i
might have thought in my heart of hearts
was so incredible
that doesn't matter i have to open my
mind up to what other people think and
accept it
i was trying to understand and learn
that as a 16 year old 17 year old before
i got to brighton um
when we were me and my brother and and
tom we were in a band as
13 14 year olds and then we were in
another one as 15 16 year olds and and
16 17 and to 18 into 19 then i left the
bands kept changing i just said another
one and another one often i was moving
it on
right because
uh
something wasn't quite good enough and
so i thought well let's change it into
this and let's change it into this thing
and let's tweak that bit and that bit
and let's make that bit better and we'll
change the band name and we'll be this
and it'll be fresh for people and then
we'll keep them
i don't know why i was thinking about
that back then in such a sort of like a
r kind of
mindset but
i was and i still sort of do
when you so six weeks after that clip of
you singing in a pub yeah um
six weeks after that clip goes online
you end up signing a record deal in new
york right yeah it was there was two
visits to new york so it was probably
more like sort of a couple of months two
or three years for the story to say six
let's go six
it was actually it was 98 days yeah
and four hours very quickly after that
clip you end up signing this record deal
and then soon after that your first ep
comes yeah to the world the dark of the
morning yeah
five tracks i listened to it earlier on
oh yeah
wasn't on spotify so i had to go on
sorry about the music there you go okay
you're only 16 quid
i wish it
thank you what was that like then that
first ep goes out into the world does
your life change at that point
um
there was a change
it all felt too fast i think once i once
i signed a record deal
as exciting as the initial sort of part
of the ride was
everything started to move quite fast
and in hindsight what i realized
i was nervous about the pace of things
but i had this
huge
um
i don't know what to call it it's a
record label obviously this this this
this huge like backing this body of
people
who wholeheartedly believed in me and
wanted to sort of throw me kind of in at
the deep end but really just sort of
throw me in the ocean
where it's all really going on i've been
like on the shore training open mic
nights little shows solo acoustic stuff
whatever writing trying to get better
staying up all night writing using all
that idle time learning to swim learning
to swim
and then they they basically looked at
me having visited uh new york a couple
times and played them some songs and
gone oh you're ready to be in the sea
you're not like surfing a big wave yet
but we're gonna put you in the c now and
i was like
whoa
um
so it it it was fast uh but within a
year you've got a headline sold out uk
tour yeah that was and and you know on
the one hand yes on the other hand it
was rooms full of 50 to 100 people but
they were all there to see me
for the first time ever
they were all they'd all bought a ticket
because somehow they found my music
they'd found the ep which again like
because of where streaming was at it
didn't go straight onto spotify and
apple and all that stuff
it was some like soundcloud like thing
it wasn't even soundcloud that it went
on to where people had to go and find it
and they think they hadn't they had a
choice maybe to pay pay if they wanted
to which is kind of sweet burn camp days
kind of yeah but it wasn't okay in camp
i mean i don't know i wasn't there yet
but
um
so i had those songs
and they they were like let's record
there was like couple of months between
signing recording that ep and releasing
it
it felt very fast and it was exciting
but yeah i've been in this training
mentality where which i was doing kind
of at my own pace i was trying to do it
all the time i was constantly training
as i say
but i didn't i didn't appreciate there
would kind of be an end to that in a way
in another respect i'm sort of still
training but at that time with what was
going on it was like no we're going to
step up a gear now and there's a few
more people involved and they're going
to push you onto bigger stages literally
and metaphorically
um
so
i didn't feel fully ready for it and i'm
kind of glad i don't think you're
supposed to ever be completely ready for
any of these things
things move even faster from then on
right because your
your second eb comes out let it go and
your album comes out in the same year
album was march 2015.
okay ep was was so same six months it
was 2014 into 2015. and uh let it go
um
had come out towards the end of the
summer before and and then and then
the album in 2015 and
uh
i remember let it go as a song
i loved the song i've never known really
i can't write a song and say that's a
hit guys
that's just not
i can't i don't do that um i've tried
i've tried but it's not really sort of
my calling to be able to do that i write
the songs and i remember writing hold
back the river and everybody at the
label and my managers everyone sort of
jumping for joy and thinking that they
had a hit on their hands which is very
exciting to be a part of and i think at
the time i thought really how do you
know that and then they worked they did
their thing they went to work and they
got that song around the world
and i got that song around the world i
suppose as well
um
and it kind of took off but let it go it
was an interesting moment because i
remember doing lots of different
festivals in america and all around the
world
i remember a place there's a festival
called outside lands which is in san
francisco or near san francisco
and um
i i got on stage in this sort of valley
type shaped bit of land
throughout this outdoors festival
because there were sort of banks of
grass at the sides quite a big stage and
it felt like quite a lot of people saw
three four thousand people i was like
wow this is exciting
and they all sang the words to let it go
every single word particularly the
choruses and we filmed it as well like
on my phone or whatever and it was
amazing and i came off stage and the
promoter said
i hadn't i hadn't met him i was like one
of the newer artists on the festival he
said that was incredible he said you're
in front of 20 000 people
i there like no way
i said they were all yeah they're all
singing the words he said yeah 20 000
people
singing the words he said we'll have you
back
i said thanks and i sort of went on my
way but um
that was a real moment where everyone
recognized that there was whole back of
the river and there was let it go as
well and let it go might be able to
carry this album as well so that was
things moved faster again i remember
actually as far as things moving fast
we got on a plane after that show in san
francisco at that festival we flew down
to l.a we crossed the airport we got on
a plane to australia we flew for 15
hours we did a show
in sydney
and then we got on a plane and we flew
back to l.a and carried on the tour so
we went to
sydney to do a show for about we went to
sydney for about barely 36 hours
30 of them are on a plane
where's the idle time
out of time on a plane is like not
whatever but it's all sort of cracked up
to be you can't get your guitar out and
start writing so um
i guess it's like emergency rest time in
a way and try and get your head down on
a plane which is as we all know kind of
tough but
um
yeah it idle time starts to sort of
disappear a little bit and it felt like
writing a song in a hotel room on tour
felt like such a heavy cliche to me that
i was never very good at that either
i've got better at it now
but we had a lot of time in hotels and i
was crap at using that that idle time to
to write more songs
what did you feel like throughout that
process so you put you know you put the
album out um
in 2015.
it was right so 2015 put the album out
that is a smash hit
um
let it go one of my favorite songs oh
it's so funny because when i listen to
that song it takes me back to so many
times in my life yeah so many times in
my life
i was listening to it before and i
almost start to feel the feelings of
like
the relationship heartbreaking that i
was going through when i was when i was
that age funny man bro i played that
song all the time
all the time thank you
it's funny how music has that power of
just sending you back to
for what it's worth just as a sort of
maybe an interesting little sort of side
fact i recorded that album at the end of
2013 and at the beginning of 2014. i
took two stints
and it came out in 2015 um but i
finished recording in january 2014.
uh
september 2020 was the first time i
listened to it after i finished
recording it well i just
i played those songs so much and i had
the time in my life but like i just i
didn't
you know it's gonna have something to do
with the bit of perfectionist in me and
we all have a bit of that but like
so much sort of pressure
and hype felt felt heaped onto that
first release for me that first big
album release
that i couldn't listen to it
and i still don't really i mean i don't
i suppose typically i don't spend my
time listening to my music once it's out
i have to do so much listening as we're
finishing the productions and the mixing
and then once it's out it's it's less
for me
it's so much for the fans but
the the frenzy around that music on the
first album
in a ways and i don't um
i don't resent anything or anyone here
but i it stopped me listening to it i
was playing those songs every day
somewhere in the world live
and um
yeah i didn't i didn't feel a need or a
desire to listen to it at all so it was
interesting
six seven years later listening sort of
for the first time and for the first
time listening and going this is decent
this is okay
work harder though keep trying that's
really the other voice that sort of
rings in my ears
chaos in the calm comes out
davey's number one
that's crazy
yeah wow the things that that sort of
does to
you emotionally and psychologically and
that i it's a it's a
it's a little bit of a trauma in its way
actually i was this not to sort of drop
names um that's not really my style but
i was at a show a great artist called
maggie rogers who was just fantastic i
know maggie and i'm a big fan at the
same time and i was watching the show
with sam smith
and niall from one direction um
three of us are watching the show in la
and it's like her her debut album show
and she's had a really great reception
particularly in america but in various
corners of the world as well
and it's a party it's like a big event
it's really fun and she's playing a
great show and sam said
she's about to go on a roller coaster
ride and it will involve trauma and it
is trauma he said
and we know all about it
each each one of us three he was talking
to me and niall he said we know
what that's like and he said we know
that nothing could prepare us could have
prepared us for it and that nobody could
have made us understand it was going to
be traumatic in a way
um beforehand
and we we we see it now with maggie and
we're fans of hers and we're so excited
and we can't you can't communicate that
to someone and because i use the word
trauma it's good and bad
and again i wouldn't change a thing and
i don't think sam would or nile or
maggie i don't think any of them would
change a thing about their ascents
that they went through
but you just said to me chaos from the
carmen's you know debut album went
straight to number one it did and it was
amazing
and i'm still trying to work it out to
this day
you know when i talk about sort of
trauma because it really affects and
changes
someone's life and changed my life
um and i love so much about what
happened and i would i would love to
experience that again
um but also it it changed so much about
me and my life
and i'm still trying to work that out
does any of that make sense all of it
makes sense cool the part of the trauma
that changed you
what is that part
great expectations follow
that's difficult
and i thought my duty
was to come with something brand new
again second album third album and i'm
i'm having a great time i've just put
out my third album and i'm i'm i can't
believe i even get to say that it went
in it was number four it's a top five
album not everybody got gets to say that
about their third album so i'm so
grateful for the reaction i really am
and yet there's a part of me that you
know
spent such a long time promoting that
first album after it came out that you
know
uh
i would like to create that exact same
experience again for different music
that i've made
that is easier said than done
every single time the chances of anyone
getting a number one album at any time
there's only one number one spot you
know
me
as a lover of so much music
with so many influences and inspirations
different artists records songs
i put a handful of those into
at the end of the day i put a handful of
those into my first album what inspired
it you know and then that created uh me
as an artist and i arrived you know the
shock of the new
on my debut album and a bunch of people
around the world said yeah
i'll buy that literally and
metaphorically i'll buy that i'm into
that
and i represented something to them
i can't believe that to this day i can't
believe i represented something to them
that they were willing to sort of buy
into and want to share and kind of agree
with and feel the words and the melodies
in in their way
and then another album it's time for
another album
it was about
showing a different side to myself
and i appreciate now in the fullness of
time with the greatest perspective or
with greater perspective
years after my second album release
that only i am in my head
nobody else is
so um
it was interesting who
uh received the second album who who
of all the people that got on board for
the release of my first album and
followed my music and me as an artist
some of them came for the second album
some of them i guess kind of went oh
it's not the same thing so
i'll just sort of come back when maybe
it's i don't i can't sort of speak for
people
but um
my expectation
naively was that i could do the same
thing again by surprising people with
something they hadn't had before because
they hadn't had my debut album before
and um
it didn't quite go
the way i hoped it would go
as i say that i don't want to sound
ungrateful because i had
so many people around the world
really love my second album
and i'm so grateful for those people
um
it peaked at number two in the album
charlotte yeah i can't i really cannot
complain in the slightest and when the
one above it is this it's a soundtrack
to a movie it was the greatest showman
that that just
reigned supreme for so long in 2018 at
the top of the charts there was various
number of other artists who didn't
unfortunately sort of beat
that soundtrack either so they all kind
of went to number two as well
but it did it peaked at number two
people loved it and they're still
telling me that they do and i'm you know
it's there's a there's a real sort of a
clash between
my gratitude towards all of those that
reception and the other part of my
brain that i suppose bought into the
hype of my first album and wanted the
same frenzy
in hindsight now if you could go back
and you could just move the order of
things
you know what i'm going to say right you
could just move the order of things
would you
maybe put you know
electric light first oh good i don't
know because then that would have
managed the expectations right the
expectations was always the curse of
happiness it's always the killer thing
because if i told you when you were
whatever age yeah your album would date
would peak at number two in the album
charts you'd be the [ __ ] moon i would
leak yeah
jump for joy yeah definitely
sorry that's awesome
we go again on that i would jump for joy
i did not mean that sorry but would you
move the order of things honestly no
no
no no no no no no
i wouldn't move the order of things at
all um because the psychological
difficulty
comes from
purely the fact that you have to almost
compete with your own success right yes
it does but it was all my choice at the
end of the day and i do stand by i love
electric light and um it came when it
came i i what's interesting is
electric light i'm so proud of and i
adore it every song it was also a
reaction to what i felt personally to me
was was like almost overkill on my first
album i had had enough
of
who i was when i was roaming around the
world
on the chaos and the calm campaign
what i represented and the songs that i
was playing
i needed to stop all of that for a
minute
for two reasons one it was exhausting
i'm
i keep wanting to throw this in i was
very grateful to have that experience
like beyond grateful
but i just for my soul and my mental
health i needed to
creatively kind of go elsewhere
um
uh so so
so i did and i also just had like i say
to you as a creative
more than one thing or one set of things
inspires me to do what i do
and i wanted to celebrate that in the
music i created for a second album
so i
went deep on david bowie and blondie and
prince and lcd sound system all that
list of artists and more i love love
that music
and uh
i don't know that that resonated in the
same way with all the fans of the first
album it certainly did with some of them
and maybe it didn't so much with others
um
i can't control any of that
the only thing i can control is what i
create
and that i do there is there is so much
of a part of what i create that i do for
myself which i think is the same for
every artist
um
so
so i chose to do that
uh
so you see what i'm saying in ways it
was a reaction
to
something i needed to do as a reaction
to how my first album campaign had gone
we wouldn't have changed the the things
around you know the order of things when
you when you spoke about mental health
yeah when was your first sort of
introduction to mental health good
question um because it of course has
become so
talked about in the last five years it's
suddenly become like
more okay than ever to speak openly
about it my first introduction to mental
health when i asked that question i mean
you're i remember at one point thinking
so the timeline of my relationship with
mental health is people with mental
health at one point maybe 10 15 years
ago when i was younger i thought it
meant that you were crazy and then as as
i experienced things myself and then
there was a word for them i understood
that we all have mental health yeah and
that we're all none of us are too tough
to experience different mental health
predicaments at times and then going
through my own journey with mental
health that's when i was like ah okay i
understand now
as a kid i thought it meant someone was
unhappy and you couldn't help them
depressed
and and unable to be helped um
and as i grew up
i remember struggling with you know as a
teenager
to be male and talk about your
feelings
wasn't
the should never be the sort of first
choice
i i remember feeling like it was
it was more about can you suck it up
though it's like your dad talking
my dad has been
been on his own journey with mental
health previous to me even being
born he he had some struggles and he did
he did talk to some professionals about
it and i really respect that
so actually it wasn't my dad talking
um
it's funny though
he comes from those kind of attitudes
both my parents come from those kind of
attitudes
you know
it's that stiff upper lip thing again
that kind of brush it all under the rug
thing again
i come from that
you know difficult things we don't talk
about then or we shout about them
no in between
and i didn't want the chaos of
the shouting as a kid and as a teenager
i never wanted that
it was always too much to deal with
so
i joined the sort of brush it under the
rug brigade
um
and
so it took me until i was into my 20s it
took me until i was touring
extensively and relentlessly
so really only five six maybe seven
years ago for me to sort of finally
understand that life can take a toll on
people
when it's when it when it's relentless
when work is relentless or when anything
in life is sort of relentless and
weighing down or bearing heavy
it can take a toll and it's okay
to talk about that to try and relieve
some pressure and some strain and some
stress
that came as a result of various
individuals that i was touring with or
that i knew doing their own touring
needing to stop for a bit
maybe speak to a therapist
to help them
and that it was okay
so it only came in the last sort of
few years for me
reading back through your story 2019 was
a bit of a mixture that's when you did
the tour with uh ed sheeran
and i i was reading about almost this
conflict that you're undergoing which is
i need to show up and perform and be who
i you know who i have this
responsibility to be but also this other
conflict of like you just weren't
feeling good
yeah
uh
i sort of encountered various sort of
people fans
or not or people i work with or people
interviewing me or whatever who and this
is ultimately like really quite
flattering they think i'm
you know
i don't know how to put it other than
like bigger than i feel i am
as an artist
i don't know if i agree with them
and so i felt like an imposter syndrome
essentially in that time
uh on the one hand i'm being you know
it's really disproportionate and and and
probably unhealthy when i think okay ed
sheeran has invited me to open for him
in football stadiums around europe for
three months there's 80 000 people every
night
wow
and the bit i hate to admit and i'm
anxious to confess is that there's a
part there's a voice in my head saying
why aren't you doing the stadiums you
call myself all sorts of names
why isn't it your show
come on
i feel
ridiculous saying that
i also just it's a little embarrassing
because
i'm doing good
and
i don't want to sort of get ahead of my
station or i don't want to seem like big
headed but i tell you i am very
ambitious and driven
everybody is i understand that and i am
in my way
and so i do want those kind of
uh
rewards of selling out such an enormous
venue and so many and so often
in the way that
he adds an example and and also i will
say that
he he was kind enough to have me on that
tour as the main support act who would
go on
right before him there was three of us
most of the time
you know open a second opener me the
third opener and then him
and it it was pretty
wonderful and exciting to find that in
in
almost every stadium it was it was a
third of that crowd which rounds out
approximately 20 or 30 000 people
singing all the words to my songs which
was just
again i was very thankful in that moment
that he brought me in front of such big
crowds because it was exciting to see
that i
my music was still reaching
and it stopped my ambitions and my drive
feeling silly
the bit the bit i was a little bit
confused about there is you're saying
you felt like an imposter in those
moments but the voice is saying so i
would expect the voice in your head to
be saying why are you here but the voice
in your head is saying why aren't you at
the top of the bell why isn't it your
show why don't you have your own stadium
show or you know even a you know arena
show or whatever it may be why your
crowd's not bigger yet james
gosh that's such an insidious thought
isn't it because
if you're
james bay big and you still
have that voice whispering about that
[ __ ] me yeah it's pretty [ __ ] intense
and i appreciate
that like
it's probably a bit cruel
cruel is a good word
it's just a it's a standard issue i
suppose it's a sort of sorry it's a
standards issue it's i i you know i'm
holding myself to a standard that
might be unrealistic but then i'm so
driven and i f or i feel so driven and
ambitious to achieve those kinds of
things that i can't shake that
voice
where's that voice coming from
deep inside um
deep inside because it's it's it's sort
of a voice i recognize from
various chapters of my life
uh
it's
on the one hand i was i was too sort of
timid and uninterested in in drinking
and partying as a teenager to sort of go
out and get amongst it on the other hand
that voice was talking to me back then
saying
don't waste your time doing that james
get better at songwriting get better at
singing get better at playing guitar
to the point where it's it's you know
you're able to confidently play well
and and make it look effortless
get to that point
and then you know then maybe we can have
a night off well you got to that point
i'm still i'm still yeah i'm still
working
in my mind is there not a bit of a fear
in in terms of listen if i'm if i'm
playing in a big arena there's 20 000
people they're all singing the words
back to me and i still have that voice
whispering inside my head saying this is
not enough or you've not achieved enough
then that voice will always be there
regardless of the the height or how high
you are i think so
i think therefore trying to kind of come
to terms with it is one of my big
exercises at the moment because it's
holding your happiness hostage right
kind of yes and i know that it's winding
up my managers for example who i've have
a very close and long-standing
relationship with people i cherish
and they're saying james like mate
um
you you've got to sort of reign that in
you've got to try and find a way to
round that in because
because it's okay
more okay then i've i'm i'm able to
realize half the time so
um
and i don't want to jeopardize my
relationship with them or or all sorts
of people
um
i'm working out therefore that i can
potentially control
some of the unhappiness
and and make my life better and easier
as a result
i'm just trying to
tame
the various voices
what do those voices say today
they say
some of them say well it's very nice to
be here
you've been invited to
talk on this on this podcast that's had
so many exciting guests
some of those voices say
yeah they just they had someone pull out
so they've got you last minute because
you know they you know there was someone
exciting who
who you know who clearly
you're a backup you're just you're just
a backup you know you're just somebody
who they thought all right i guess you
know there's a there's a voice that's
quite extensive in those kind of details
and and sort of takes me apart a little
bit
um so it's it's versions of one of that
one voice and it's versions of that
other voice that are
speaking
often in my head and and that's what
they're saying
all of these voices they have they have
adverse consequences some of those
consequences are positive
in the light of the world they turn into
drive and motivation or perfectionism
right which end up producing really
wonderful art obviously some of the
consequences of those voices can be very
um personally as it relates to your
happiness detrimental right
talk to me first about because i want to
talk about the positives that those
voices that have you know manifestation
on that side but talk to me about the
the
negative detrimental impact of being
having those voices
the longer i sort of exist with these
voices the the the the negative ones um
the more they can have an effect
unfortunately a negative effect the more
that they can sort of um
they can
stop me going out into the world and
doing certain things
you know the more they can get into my
head and sort of inhibit my ability to
sort of
speak to you in a free-flowing way for
example
or
um
go to a party i've been invited to by an
artist i might know or by by somebody
whose work i might admire i'm being sort
of hypothetical in that respect but it
could very much sort of be a that could
be a reality
and the benefits of coming and speaking
to you and the benefits of
going to some party or whatever
are just that those are the things that
color life and that's that's just a good
thing um
but sometimes the voices get so loud
that that i don't go and do these things
and i and and
i my life remains kind of gray
just personally and privately
and that's not helpful to when i get
that idle time back
in the moments that i do
because all the things that color life
feed
wonderfully in my most of my experience
into that idle time
whether i do create something or not
um
so they they are an obstacle they are a
barrier
those those negative voices and
i'm trying to grow and get better at
sort of managing them and dealing with
them
and understanding that no voices
no narratives kind of go away entirely
happy or sad
they they don't
you know 2019 was a difficult year and
i've learned since then
through various types of therapy
one of those is songwriting for me
another one is typical sort of therapy
as we know it speaking to somebody
i've i've i've learned a little bit more
about
sort of being able to quiet the the
negative voices or control them a little
bit
um
you can never do any one of these things
a hundred percent
i'm i'm learning um and there's a part
of my mind that wants a hundred percent
yeah here they are everywhere 100 be the
headliner at this thing 100 be able to
stop those voices so they never come
back
and i'm just still sort of trying to
learn that there's no 100 anything
anywhere
everything is a as a gentle sort of
balance
that's a really liberating thought
though because there's so many people
that are still struggling with things
after many decades and that will beat
themselves up because it's still there
yeah and and i actually had this
conversation this week this weekend i
think this weekend yeah it was on
saturday morning with my girlfriend
where i said one of the things i've come
to learn from doing this podcast and
just my own sort of early traumas is
that we shouldn't hold ourselves to the
standard of completely riddling
ourselves of our trauma or insecurities
it's really about diminishing the power
they have over you to the point that
your decision making can be made through
another set of stories yeah so like with
relationships we had a lot of traumas so
i still have those and i'm still i still
think to some degree a relationship is
prison maybe 40 percent now it's still
there but the 60 percent is like you're
being an idiot [ __ ] get on with it
and it's 60 rather
you know so it makes the decision but so
yeah
perspective
trying to sort of gather a better and a
broader perspective
on your present circumstance or whatever
or me on my present sort of circumstance
trying to sort of get the full context
certainly helps the negative voices
quiet down a little bit in 2019 you said
you described it as feeling like you
were drowning yeah and that was
definitely had a lot to do with the the
the negative voices and feeling like
they were all getting way too loud and
way too much and way too overpowering
and and it could feel at times like i
was sort of drowning in those and there
was such a stark contrast between the
walking on stage with the big sort of
smile and the and the ground gestures
and the performance
because that's a real spike in the day
it's a real high it's wonderful and it's
a real process and i know it to the
point that a lot of it
is sort of like muscle memory
i'm in the moment no question i'm in the
moment i'm very present
but i know how to do all sorts of things
on stage and i know i'm good at them and
i've done them for 35 minutes and i'm
off stage and the voices are back i'm
walking down the steps from the stage
and the voices are back in there um
saying what
saying could have been better
saying
they're just waiting for ed sheeran on
that tour so which they were granted but
like
um
they'd take even something like that
that was okay you know it's okay that
you know it's very exciting and
flattering and humbling that i've been
invited to open on that tour
and that's what it is
but the voices were turning those things
around on me
and saying and using them as a reason to
tell me i wasn't good enough what has
therapy taught you about that
those voices well the things i've just
said really they've it's therapies
taught me
um
very sort of
crucially it's taught me that they're
not going to go away entirely and i
think that's been a really important
thing to learn and talk about again and
again and again because i can be quite
um
uh
i can't think of the word but i i would
absolutely like like to work out how
what the ingredients what the recipe is
to get them to go away forever i'd like
to know what it is
and use it and be done with it and never
hear from them again and so therapy's
teaching me still
that
um
it's actually it's not that's not the
process the process is about
talking
with them and asking them hey you know
reasoning with myself
reasoning with them
bringing in more context
um
bringing in a broader perspective
and then asking myself you know
are these voices right honestly
because in the worst moments i'm saying
yet you're absolutely right to all these
voices and i'm not good enough
in 2019 when you feel like you're
drowning what are the symptoms of that
what are the what would i what are they
that's a heart that's a good question a
hard one to answer the symptoms are so
invisible to most people everybody
really
and often me
because i'm i i feel a sort of duty
sadly sometimes in my personal life
private life as well to be so on
so much of the time sometimes as a you
know like a sort of drug i use to keep
myself high
it feels like that
because that means that i don't have to
feel the sort of despair
um
you know i again like when i go back to
my parents my my family my home life
they had lots of people around very
social people
and everything was very
um up
or it was shouting
and
fury
or it was like calm water
there was no in between
um
and it sort of it turned me into this
person where
you know if if if there are two sides
and a river in between
and
you know there are two banks and i'm on
one bank and i want to get to the other
bank
um
i always try and jump over the river
uh and that's not that's that i need to
get better at getting in the water
getting a bit wet
wading through against the currents that
are trying to send me downstream
and like climbing out the other side
and drying off and it all taking the
time that it takes because you typically
like the river i'm talking about is
never any less than like
20 feet wide so i'm not jumping over it
you can't
i can't fly
i'm gonna have to just get in the water
and go through what is the river in that
metaphor um
the river is so many things in that
metaphor
uh it's all
it's it's the the river is the dealing
with those voices
it's probably confronting you know some
of the issues that i've carried forward
from
from my sort of childhood
if not a lot of those issues
the river is
the fighting within an imposter syndrome
an issue with imposter syndrome
um
the river is kind of a lot of the sort
of demons that i have ultimately um
but but but getting in the water would
give me sort of perspective
and wading through
that teaches a lot probably about like
it being everything being about the
journey rather than the destination
in my in my household at home it was
about
we're furious we need to get to not
furious so we'll force ourselves
straight there by blocking things out
and there'll be no processing and
talking about who feels what and how and
how it makes them fit this out the other
um
the perspective is
is
you know very important zooming out in
in my life i find is is helpful very
often
somebody actually not to go off on too
much of a tangent here but it really
resonated with me only a couple of days
ago someone from my label was telling me
about her time a long time ago now
actually but she was working with the
bee gees and it was in the early 90s
and their household name to us today we
know everybody knows that bg's music
like they know
other household names and
this lady was talking to me she was
saying she said i was about to turn 34
and i was working with barry gibb
and he said um
what do you think of my music what do
you think of me as an artist she's been
quite open with him about i'm about 10
34 i'm ancient people in pop music think
they're ancient beyond 21.
everybody
um
and he he said no you're not no you're
not in that ancient they'd be silly
because he was in his 50s or something
at the time
he said what do you think of my music
what do you what do you know about me
she says you're a legend she said you're
just you're a household named legend i
love all your records you're brilliant
he said you know what he said to her
when i was 33 i just got divorced i've
fallen out with my brothers
um i hadn't had a song on the radio for
years
uh if we were doing any gigs we were
playing working men's clubs
this was the late 70s i think
and he said i was 33 and we'd had our
initial sort of spike our high our hits
late 60s very early 70s
we had it all and it went away and i
always believed
that in pop and in music and in
entertainment you have you you have your
big moment and then it's all down from
there
um
he said and then someone offered us the
opportunity to write a soundtrack for a
movie the movie was saturday night fever
and obviously ever since then you know
he's talking as a 50 something year old
he said it's just been up and up and up
from there
and now you're telling me i'm a
household name he said i unfortunately
if i'm honest he said i still struggle
with all sorts of these demons that i'm
not good enough and having this and that
success
but he said i've got more perspective
now and i appreciate
when you tell me that you know you think
my work is so
well known
and i thought
before all that that it was all over i
just thought it was a decent bit of
wisdom from obviously yes granted he's a
total legend and
you know he's
gonna be quite a good example in that
respect but like
so easy to slip into that mindset of
like it's all done you've had your time
but life is long
hmm
i'm trying to remind myself for that
knew what 31 yeah
[ __ ] nuts ancient knife
that is so most people don't start their
careers by that point yeah i i
yeah
i guess
you know
but the drive is there i keep coming
back to things i've said before the
ambition is there i've
you know i'm very hungry to to
be doing it
what are you hungry for
connection
so my favorite thing about where does
that come from
um in music
performance
creating creating writing recording
releasing performing
there in all of that is so many
opportunities for connection not just
for fans but with people i work with as
well i cherish my working relationships
i don't love
lots of people coming in and out of my
my sort of work circle i like to grow
with people is there this weird paradox
of the thing you're chasing in terms of
like you know that peak again you talked
about this like big moment that you were
you know you stood there and you watched
this young artist who you know is going
to go through it
but at the same time knowing that there
comes a real cost with that
that because i sometimes when i speak to
musicians it's i have that a lot where
they're like
i think i'm thinking of craig david who
i think he had his one number one album
at 18.
you know quite honestly says you know
i'm looking for that moment again but it
was also pretty much the worst moment of
my life
and it's funny man yeah and it does come
back to that when i referenced trauma
and maggie's concert and sam what he was
saying and
um
it's funny how that that that works but
we see
there are some real
one-in-a-millionaires
who might have two three four
consecutive
peaks
um
and
all
everybody else looks at that and even
the people who go through that look at
it as like but something could be better
it's funny i can't explain that and i
suffer from it like so many people do
um
but if nothing else
it's because i really care about and
love what i do and i really want to be
in it i really want to be
kind of on the pitch
i've
slipped into a football analogy but for
good reasons or for like slightly toxic
insidious like
because i love the game
for good reasons
are you sure
yeah you're sure it's good reasons oh
yeah i'm talking about the
the accolades here though because number
one is just a comparative measure so
okay and actually i'm the same i'm
playing devil's advocate for the sake of
conversation that's that's fair and
number one is just a comparative measure
there's nothing inherently special about
it other than you are better than
someone else i can't on that just
quickly on that i can't tell you how
many times uh people i work with have
sort of like and and me as well we've
we've gone wow our grammy would be great
wouldn't it yeah that would be awesome
and we've also said like five would be
awesome and we all know that 10 would be
incredible
and just off the top of my head a
household name legend called david bowie
got one i think posthumous
grammy award for a music video
and the the grammy award one for the
music video is just as valid as the rest
of them but it's a little further down
the list
you know the big record of the year
artist of the year all those ones are
the the most exciting ones
apparently and um
and he didn't suffer it seems for for
that one music video
grammy award
and there's a handful of my other
absolute favorite artists of all time
who have recognized all around the world
who haven't got near to
certain awards ceremonies or whatever
and it just couldn't matter so but i
suppose my point is that i've found it
unfortunately easy to get wrapped up in
the hype of those
those things
um
i hate to confess that
but part of my working through it all is
is
getting out into the open so i can hear
it sort of with my own ears as well
because
music is not those things it's
so much more than that and that's why i
fell in love with it as a small child
in a way that i feel is the same as i
love it now
i love it just as much i'm just as blown
away by great music
as i was when i was i don't even know
how young
let's talk about your new music sure
your new album you know
yeah let's we can do that i struggle i
struggle talking about my stuff
um
but let's talk about it why do you
struggle talking about it
uh your body language has shifted
somewhat yeah because
i feel like a salesman
oh right
um that's fine no i you know i
also the other reason i feel like a
salesman sometimes you know but also the
other reason is that like
these songs that
they mean a lot to me i just i write
about things that
mean a lot
in my life you know there's been a
degree of sort of vulnerability that
i've sort of gone to in the writing of
these songs for this new album leap
that i don't feel i have been able to
tap into before and reach
so um this is why i asked you the
question about your affectionate parents
right
because you've clearly been on that
journey of learning how to be a
different type of um vulnerable
you know the yeah you talk about it like
the thank you i love you vulnerable yeah
yeah that's why i was searching for when
i asked that question at the start
whether you had a lot of i love you
thank yous at home i'm just remembering
that whatever i said was sort of we just
laughed because it was so [ __ ]
stunted whatever i said go on sorry no
that's the point that was that's why i
asked the question because you know
you've been on that journey of trying to
be a different type of vulnerable yes
yes um and that's becoming more evident
yeah
i i you you're feeling it does in this
new music 100 i'm really glad and that
you feel that because i'm trying to
access that for all the reasons that
you're sort of circling around actually
yes that optimism as well comes through
in a big way well and when you talk
about you know i'm trying to access a
different kind of affection i am and i
had said to you i am trying to access
that and i had said to you
that i felt like i was i have grown up
to be a different kind of affectionate
than than the people i grew up around my
immediate family um yeah i'm not afraid
to say that because i don't criticize
them
um for how they were affectionate it was
different
it was different and as a result and
i've talked about it um and i will talk
about it now like in the writing of this
album
it's taken me going into a
a new depth of vulnerability to find
ways to say in songs
these things i love you these things
like i need you these things like thank
you
because those those phrases were not
thrown around freely in my in my house
it's not to say they didn't exist in my
house when i was a kid it's not to say
they didn't exist there
but i'm not used to that
environment
but i want it
and i've had a baby and i i i want it in
her life and i didn't write these songs
when she was she wasn't here yet when i
wrote these songs but for half of them i
knew she was on the way
so it changed my perspective again and
it probably did affect the writing
um but it
it's it's it's all you know
sort of so honest that it that it's of
course rooted in
feelings that are about me
uh and how i feel
and i just i'm trying to change the
landscape
my immediate sort of landscape in my
life my personal life
and that's why songwriting is such a
therapy can be such a therapy for me
because those those very personal issues
and scenarios will will come out in my
songs
and then i'm i'm actually glad to say
that i've i've arrived now on this third
album with songs that manage to say
those affectionate things that we've now
listed a number of times that i'll
happily list again but probably feel a
little probably make me feel a little
bit uncomfortable so funny but yeah
there's a song called there's a whole
bunch of songs this album i could
happily and easily reference but one
life has been a big moment one life is a
song that has been a was a big turning
point in the writing
i love the gesture i've only got one
life and i want you in it um as a lyric
uh as a notion who's that for lucy
110 000
what does she mean to you everything
why
she knew me before i
you know got near
the music industry
i think she she knew me who went
together but she knew me but like
intimately as a friend before
i even
was certain how much i i definitely
wanted to leave my safe little hometown
venture into the big wide world and try
and
do music
um
[Music]
and she's
wanted to sort of stick with me ever
since and there were many years when we
had no idea
where it was going or if it was going
anywhere and we're still not certain
we still we still live every day like
it's like it could all be gone tomorrow
and i and and
you know as a result in the healthiest
way i can possibly express i feel like i
need her
she's got the most um
healthy and brilliant [ __ ] radar
i've ever met
you know
mine's not so good
mine's sort of attracted to the shiny
things
and the shiny possibilities and she's
like
i suppose i'll say she's got my back
often better than i have
um have you told her how much you
appreciate her in person
i hope so
i
i
i
i do try to
and you know what
in a beautiful way
she'll say yeah i shout
you know she'll say like
yeah all right
she'll she will give me the time of day
but she's steely and i love that
and she's driven
and she's ambitious for me for us for
her for our family
but i do tell her
i do talk to her about it
what do you think your life would be
like without her
god forbid
calamitous
tragic
difficult
difficult
um
she sort of helps
tame my kind of
wild emotions
she absolutely sort of she knows them so
well and she she i mean i think it's
important to say like
and i do the same for her
she knows how to let them kind of run
wild and free
but she knows how to sort of
sharpen my focus
when i'm struggling to do it for myself
um
yeah
she's quite vital
and i'm very okay with saying that
uh
we've been on a journey man we've you
know
we really have
and i can't you know we continue to to
get to be on one and that's just
it's so important to me
it's a beautiful balance
it's a beautiful balance
it's a it's a beautiful thing to to hear
i mean
you've known this person since you're
seventeen uh i've noticed i was 15 15.
you got together when you were 17. so
you've been together somewhat 13 14
years now that's
that's one hell of an achievement and uh
especially because you often hear that
those earlier relationships when you
really are changing and figuring out who
you are are the hardest to ever hold on
to because it's kind of like how is the
analogy i always think of it's almost
like two parallel lines but at the start
of our lives there these parallel lines
are like
the variance in terms of the direction
that they can go in is so far you can
become completely different person in
your 20s yes and when you're 14 you
don't know who the [ __ ] you are yeah
fitting in so to survive all of all of
those chapters
it's amazing i can't explain it fully
it feels like a wonderful sort of
coincidence sometimes that we've you
know we've
we all here we are all falling through
life
and our paths have never veered too far
away from each other's
there's something
about it that all kind of just comes
down to chance which i love because she
never
compromised especially in the earlier
years she had an opportunity through the
degree that she did to go to america for
a year and she did it and we decided to
sort of hold on to each other in that
time i didn't get to go
but we sort of said we'd
we'd be together and just sort of see
you on the other side sort of thing but
that's where chance goes out the window
because that's hard work true and this
is and this is some with the soul mate
analogy which can sometimes be a little
bit dangerous is
it ken i was asked if i believe in cell
mates the other day and i didn't know
what to say
um because like yes and no right like
yeah because we
yes but
it was i suppose as i look back in a
sort of pragmatic kind of fashion
at that moment when she went away
it was such a big scary big wide world
moment for her
and i went into my first year living
away from hitching my hometown first
time ever that i was like on my own
doing my shopping for myself or like you
know
paying the rent for myself
and to check in with each other every
other day
when the time uh difference allowed on
skype or whatever it was
or a very expensive text message
was so
critical
to
us
feeling all
right and all anybody's ever trying to
do
whatever age they are it's just feel all
right
um
she
helps me do that did back then and still
does and i i know i do the same for her
you know she's like a sort of anchor
and you know the rest of me is sort of
floating around in a stormy sea how much
did that go into this album leap how
much of that those feelings towards her
and that new sort of ability to be a
little bit more vulnerable uh more than
ever before
um
i i've been very honest in all of my
lyrics that i've ever written really but
but vulnerability requires me to
being vulnerable in my sort of lyric
writing requires me to kind of
be more direct and and and open up and
be more open and talk about
what i'm talking about in the songs
um
so so much of of
of
what
she means to me
went into this album
in a more vulnerable and more direct way
than it ever had before
um
and we were actually at a point i felt
like it was overdue in a way because
our choice our choice together
has been
in the last nearly 10 years
where people have known about me in some
capacity in some public capacity and
i've you know
gone around the world and sold tickets
to shows and
released music and all of this stuff and
been on tv a bit whatever
our choice together has been to keep our
private life quite private but then
there was a moment where it felt like
she didn't exist and that was just awful
it felt like that we were living a lie
so it's overdue in a way that i'm
saying this is lucy she's the she's like
one whole half of me
and
more than that here's here's what she
means to me
so on the one hand it's the first time
i've been more sort of public about
talking about my my relationship on the
other hand it's a total celebration
and rightly so
um
if she was sitting here now listen to me
say that she'd be like cool down
simmer down like you're getting a bit
over because she's most humble person
i've ever met but um
yeah it was it was sort of time
why leap
we need another two hours for that that
um um
because
it's something i needed it's a bit it's
it's been a bit of a mantra as a word
um i i sort of needed to it i've needed
to hear it i've needed to use it
i've needed to say it i've needed to
exercise it
uh
leap in the net will appear is a is a is
a phrase a quote from a guy called john
burras
he said leap in the net will appear
i read that
and it sort of blew me away
because i'm so paranoid about the net
where it is when it's going to be there
how strong it is will it hold
i hate to admit
i feel like i'm sort of revealing a side
of myself that i'm quite sort of
self-conscious about but i'm very
concerned about the net
and i'm quite um can be so reluctant to
leap
i if that's surprising to people because
they think i sort of spend my life
getting up on stage that's a different
thing i know that might be confusing in
itself but it's just something i i do
and i know how to do and i love and i've
compartmentalized it in a different
place in a different way
but just to leap in many respects sort
of
literally
uh
figuratively spiritually whatever i
struggle
what is the cost if we don't leap
you'll never know
you know
you'll never know if the net will appear
i think we want the net to appear we
want to leap do something wonderful in
the air and land safely
and if you don't leap there's no
wonderful in the air
and there's no landing safely
so you've not gone anywhere or done
anything
and then you probably did
interestingly as well i think
regardless of really what happens in the
air i think like um
the leap itself is the is life and i
think it also almost seems to be the
case like regardless of what happens in
the air you land safely part of it seems
to me that even if you land on your back
you land comfortably but i've struggled
to trust this yeah yeah
and there's been some voices in my head
that have really
um stopped me sort of trusting those
that beautiful
sort of concept that you've just sort of
presented there was your concept well
it's john burroughs no
um
can't have it back
no it's the way that you put it was
really great and and
so i've looked at it from all angles
yeah if it's my concept then then i've i
have looked at it from an angle that
from which i do celebrate it enormously
which is also the way i think you
delivered it then but i've i've also
sort of looked at it from a nervous
standpoint and not and not moved
but
in in a fight against
and in a campaign against the negativity
that i've struggled with in the last few
years
and actually a lot in my life it's not
just about 2019
i just was having a particularly
difficult time that year
um
i i wanted to use it as as a as an album
title to represent so much of what is in
these songs so much of the heart in
these songs is about
in the face of difficulty i have i have
this and this and i have you and that
references lucy quite directly most of
the time
you know that's the you i'm talking
about um
it's about silver linings
i've struggled to see them when they've
been there sometimes
and i just needed to make music
that's that that
celebrated and represented them to
remind myself
um because yeah sometimes i feel like
i'm drowning 2019
before 2019 you know
um but there is there is there is
leaping always as an option
hindsight seems to tell us that the
greatest risk is taking no risk at all
you know the greatest well the most the
most costly leap would be taking no leap
because if you think about that and
ultimately it means it means a life of
stagnation it means no
challenge it means no excitement it
means no heartbreak if you never put
yourself in a situation to even be you
know and yes so um and i've seen that
throughout my life is just that you know
sometimes when i when i think about risk
actually it's a real
misunderstanding of what the risk
actually is the risk actually was it's
funny because when i tell people i
dropped out of university started a
business this business made 700 million
whatever they go oh my gosh you're so
courageous and my head has always
struggled with that concept right i was
courageous or brave
because in my head the courageous and
brave thing to do
was staying at university
right that was the risk the risk was
staying and potentially ending up in a
life that wasn't for me the cowardice
thing to do
was
leaving and and going for it that was
the coward approach so i think sometimes
if you like really like analyze yeah you
know and sort of kind of swap the all
around you can be a bit more empowered
you throw a bunch more perspective at it
yeah exactly and sort of life context
and and yeah it's their life context
people don't realize that they're gonna
die someday
you know what i mean and i i think about
that a lot i have a sound timer i don't
know if it's behind me it's worth
reminding is that in the bottom corner
yes that's why it's there we're looking
at that guy yeah because that's the only
way you can really see
time yeah i think humans struggle with
finality
and infinity
the two concepts that something can end
and that it can last forever we don't
think we we really don't think we're
gonna die right we've heard about it
it's a story i've seen a couple of other
people do it yeah yeah but when you
think about the things you're consuming
your mind with the concerns the
procrastination this is not someone who
thinks they're going to die right you
know that there's a timer so this yeah
we think we've got time to procrastinate
yeah but now it's very true it's it's
and it's and it's
worth reminding ourselves once in a
while just turning it over yeah and oh
[ __ ] i'm going to go and leap
i'm going to go and do something i've
got to go and you know take a risk or
else i risk
nothing being my day-to-day
yeah that's um that's sort of dangerous
and
and uh
i yeah like i i was just
feeling quite sort of safe
keeping my private life private and my
but there was so much i had to say about
it
i keep my private life private and my am
i you know trying to sort of say
you know what my public life is
people who are interested
and that's that
when
i suppose i'll use this word the most
wonderful way to go about it
was to
share
in the way that i have today with you
but also
in by celebrating
one of the greatest things in my life
that will always sort of change and
evolve and has done for the time that
lucy and i have been together
um
so it it doesn't sort of set something
in stone
that i can't then you know explore sort
of sharing or you know
um
using is the wrong word
celebrating again
it's it's been it's been
sort of enlightening and
help me feel lighter
to
to share it
to celebrate
to celebrate like full stop
because it's so easy to get it's dragged
down by
sort of darker thoughts
that are always going to kind of exist
don't like forget the
the light on the horizon the silver
lining
that's there as well leonard cohen i'm
not gonna get it right but he said
something really great about like
everything has cracks in it that's how
the light gets in
you know he smashed that when he said
that
i am so excited to announce our new
sponsor for this podcast and that is
blue jeans by verizon for any of you
that aren't already familiar with
bluejeans they are a video conferencing
and collaboration tool who offer an
immersive communication experience that
drives pretty unparalleled employee and
customer engagement experiences me and
all of my teams across all of my
portfolio companies switched over to
blue jeans a couple of months ago and we
have not looked back the best thing for
us has been the totally frictionless
experience no glitching no sound issues
no delays or any of those things that
usually make virtual meetings really
really frustrating we use blue jeans
anywhere on any device at any time and
it's perfect for my small businesses
that just have 10 or 20 people to some
of my bigger businesses that have
hundreds of people i'm a big fan as you
can probably tell so i've been quite
excited for for some time to announce
this partnership and in the coming weeks
i'll explain the features and really why
it's perfect for you if you haven't
considered using or switching over to
blue jeans yet but if you can't wait
head over to bluejeans.com to learn more
honestly it's been one of the real sort
of game changers in my business
oh this is an interesting one yeah
so our previous guest leaves a question
for our next guest right
go on okay so the question they um
they left for you and i really want you
to think about this because this is a
really interesting one
is
would you do it all again
um
oh
why are you battling with that because
it's like there's consequences with her
how i ask it i want to say yes
i want to say i'd do it all again
because it was [ __ ] brilliant
i wouldn't do it all again so much of it
was brilliant but i there's a caveat to
my answer i would do it all again if you
let me
like i didn't
if i wasn't going to waste the time i
have going forward like can i just go
back in time do it all again and come
back to this moment and then carry on
from here as i was
do you see what i mean i got you i don't
want
to
fill the next 10 years
with doing the last 10 again
okay okay so but that's
doctor yeah
yeah well it would be you'd have to go
through and experience it again so the
next period of your life would be the
same thing again i'm guessing from the
question okay let's see this is what we
don't know so because my answer the
reason i say no is because i wouldn't
enjoy doing it all again because you've
done it
like i personally wouldn't get the same
oh my god oh wow oh you know yeah see i
was thinking i was i was i didn't know
that it was i've been through it before
the old men in black men in black yeah
yeah so otherwise i'm answering the same
as you okay interesting i i
there's yeah there's a there's a sort of
fantastical fantasy world within which i
would do it again where i was
where i was just doing it
but um
before i said that i thought well no i
really i'm i'm really excited about what
happens next what happens next
i don't know and that's what keeps it
exciting that's also what makes me sort
of
you know
fight with all these voices
but it's also what makes it exciting
well james um you are a person who is
particularly
enjoyable to talk to oh thanks man and i
think likewise very much likewise thank
you evidence of that comes you know when
you're looking at those music videos and
they're giving you a little bit more
depth and you're the person to try and
search out the depth from a very very
young age or clearly someone that wants
to go a little bit deeper
and that makes you a man of my own heart
because i
that's this is what i do in my spare
time probably to the detriment of you
know casual social situations
um but your new music is testament of
everything you've said today it's it's
it's evidence that you have unlocked a
new
sort of i almost thought it was like a
wall falling and like something
wonderful flowing out of it that hadn't
been there before thanks man i think
people who listen to lee are gonna are
gonna feel this conversation
um but they're also gonna feel this this
new side of you that's
um created art that feels much more
relatable because it's much more
well-rounded if that makes sense
so look thank you all right it really
you know
i'm
those are incredibly kind words and i
and i
i appreciate them
and um i'm a bit blown away so that you
that you feel that towards the music so
i'll hold on to that for sure
thank you thank you
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast my girlfriend
came upstairs yesterday when i was
having a shower and she said to me that
she tried the heel protein shake which
lives on my fridge over there and she
said it's amazing low calories you get
your 20 odd grams of protein you get
your 26 vitamins and minerals and it's
nutritionally complete in the protein
space there's lots of things but it's
hard to find something that is nice
especially when consumed just with water
and that is nutritionally complete the
salted caramel one if you put some ice
cubes in it and you put it in a blender
and you try it is as good as pretty much
any milkshake on the market just mixed
with water it's been a game changer for
me because i'm trying to drop my calorie
intake and i'm trying to be a little bit
more healthy with my diet so
this is where heel fits in my life thank
you for making a product that i actually
like
[Music]
[Music]